welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
today is professor Jennifer Ruger an
associate professor at the Yale School
of Public Health and former co-director
of the Yale World Health Organization
Center for Health Promotion policy and
research professor Ruger is working to
promote the creation of public health
programs that make more efficient use of
scarce resources while improving current
health care practices the Institute of
Medicine recently invited her to testify
about how the management of global
health institutions and governance might
be improved professor Ruger is here
today to talk about the IOM report on
global health and share some of her
insights welcome professor Ruger thank
you health care in the United States
today is complicated there are huge
disparities and a solution to those
problems seems elusive at best while
look at global health well especially in
these economic times it would be
certainly a prudent of our government to
focus on the health care system here in
the United States and there are as you
indicate a number of disparities in
health care and access and financing in
the United States that are
differentially impacting the American
citizen Sri however if you look at the
US health care system within a global
perspective we see that compared to many
developing countries the United States
health care system is actually quite
developed and quite strong for example
the expenditures for an individual on
health care in the United States are
over five thousand dollars whereas in
many developing countries we're talking
about one hundred dollars or less and
even as low as ten dollars per person in
hell
care spending also we see major
differences in the healthcare
infrastructure in developing countries
versus the United States for example the
number of physicians are nurses per
person or per 1000 people on a
population are significantly different
by even a hundred fold in the United
States versus many developing countries
and on and on there's a number of major
differences between the healthcare
system in the United States and and in
many developing countries alongside that
we see a major significant difference in
the burden of disease in developed
countries in general in the United
States and in particular and many
developing countries for example life
expectancy differences in the United
States on average Americans live over
over 70 years and in many developing
countries especially in in Africa the
life expectancy is less than 40 years or
45 years so they're major differences
and the the scope of the problem of the
healthcare system at the national level
even though we have great problems in
the United States is quite significant
in many developing country context so
the United States is interested from a
global perspective in how it can better
engage with the global community to
improve health systems in developing
countries the IOM report to which you
contributed addresses the question of
how the US government can improve global
health under the new administration
share with us some of its findings the
the Institute of Medicine recently
convened a committee and set of working
groups to focus on different areas of
global health in which the United States
can contribute and some of the main
issues that this committee was looking
at in the report of recommendations
outline around several key issues in
global health in the u.s. Israel the
first is the u.s. having a major role in
global health as a component of foreign
policy as a component of u.s. foreign
policy and the recommendation from the
report in that domain was to actually
enhance the u.s. role in global health
as a major strength of our u.s. foreign
policy the second major area of
recommendations from the report was in
the area of global health financing and
the recommendations in the report were
along a number of different areas of
financing the first was to actually
increase the amount of money that's
invested by the US government in
developing countries in global health
either multilaterally through the global
health system of global health
institutions or bilaterally directly
investing in global health from the
United States to another country the
recommendation by the report was
actually to double the investments from
seven billion dollars to over 15 billion
dollars in the new administration
another area of financing that the
report focused on and recommended was
that the actual portfolio of investments
in global health change somewhat
significantly so an emphasis was placed
on with this increase in investments
spreading the investments around
different diseases they're not just
focusing on just a particular disease
like aids or malaria or TB but focusing
on the infectious diseases and the non
communicable diseases that contribute to
the greatest burden of disease in many
countries another area was of
recommendations in terms of funding was
around strengthening health systems in
developing countries and focusing
particularly on financing and human
resources and the infrastructure of the
third area of rec
mendations for the report was around
governance issues both within the United
States in terms of its commitment to
global health and global health
governance so within the United States a
recommendation was made to coordinate
better the different policies and
programs that the United States has in
global health so when the Centers for
Disease Control is doing something and
the US Department of Health and Human
Services is doing something in the State
Department that we actually have some
sort of a coordinating mechanism and
actually there was a specific
recommendation to create an office in a
position within the White House for
global health so more coordination a
more coherent strategy within the u.s.
towards investments and work in global
health and then on the global health
governance dimension a recommendation
was made again towards greater coherence
so the US would engage with the global
health community primarily through the
World Health Organization or another
major coordinating mechanism so that the
United States along with other countries
and other different programs in global
health try to coordinate and align the
investments in global health to have
greater impact a final area of
recommendation was in the air was in
investments in health related research
at the us through the Fogarty Institute
the National Institutes of Health other
areas of health related research has
actually been very beneficial in
focusing on coming up with new
discoveries about disease diseases and
how to prevent them and treat them and
so an emphasis was made on improving and
enhancing our investments in research
related to diseases in the health
systems of development countries sounds
like a lot of good recommendations
initially you touched on foreign policy
why should health care be one of the
founding
shins of u.s. foreign policy well this
was an area of the discussions among the
committee that I found to be the most
interesting there seems to be a greater
shift in thinking about health as a
foreign policy issue now than there has
been in the past in particular previous
working global health has really
emphasized health as a part of u.s.
foreign policy in terms of America's
self-interest or what why would America
are Americans be interested in promoting
health in developing countries and why
should that be a part of our foreign
policy from our perspective in terms of
national interest and that's still a
major component of the rationale for why
the US should be evolved in global
health but it seems like there's a now
more towards the global interest and
that the US should be involved in global
health and global health should be a
part of our foreign policy because the
US as a an economically developed and
one of the more economically developed
countries a leader in global diplomacy
has a responsibility and opportunity to
enhance the global interest of reducing
the disease burden in many developing
countries and that that actually is more
of a long-term view that if the America
focuses on health as a foreign policy
issue that global interest will be
enhanced but also American interest in
the in the longer run and what does that
mean that means that health investing in
health is good for economic development
in developing countries which is
ultimately good for the United States
and for the global economy investing in
health is good for security it's better
for peace and we see many areas of the
world where their major disease burdens
and there's a great deal of civil
conflict as well so investing in health
is good for security and peace at the
global level but also for Americans
and that these ideas of investing in in
global health are also founded in
ethical commitments that it's it's
really is the right thing to do for
America so it's an it's a very
interesting having seen this over a
number of decades a very interesting
shift in the rationale for why the
United States should focus on health as
a foreign policy component and who
controls global health policies now well
global health policy is a very vague
concept it's a you know there's a lot of
groups institutions individuals
countries that are involved in global
health one term that we typically use to
describe global health policy is the
global health architecture so what are
the different institutions that are
involved in global health I would say
first and foremost is is countries
themselves national governments
ministries of health ministries of
Finance that support ministries of
Health and and fund the health systems
and public health programs and in
developing countries so I think this is
often often not as emphasized in the
global health architecture but national
governments national health programs and
at the sub-national level state and
provincial governments are important in
the global health architecture at the
global level we have a number of
different global health institutions and
that is another area that has changed
significantly in the past even in the
past five and ten years and particularly
in the past five years we've seen an
escalation of the number of players and
actors in global health we used to be
that at the global level there was more
or less the United United Nations system
with the World Health Organization UN
aids and and other UN agencies the World
Bank
and now we see a plethora of different
institutions involved we have the Global
Fund there's the PEPFAR the president's
program for AIDS we have the Gates
Foundation a number of private entities
involved in global health civil society
NGOs I mean it's just an enormous number
of different institution and actors both
on the funding and the financing of
global health but also in the input
implementation and the program
development and and policies on the
ground so one of the key issues that was
addressed in the report and that's why
the World Health Organization was
recommended as a coordinating mechanism
was that in many in many respects and
we're actually seeing this in the
evidence now at the country level a
pluralism in global health financing and
program development can be burdensome
two countries can be very difficult to
manage a number of different donors and
with different agendas and working at
cross-purposes sometimes and so an
effort was made or call to action was
taken in the report to try to find a
coordinating mechanism for trying to
really bring together these different
institutions and players around shared
objectives and I think that goes back to
the ethical commitments and also the
global interests that were the fossa of
the report that really you know all
these different institutions and players
are to be in the global health
architecture to improve health and in
developing countries and aligning our
efforts around that shared goal can
create greater impact along those lines
an emphasis was made in the report with
respect to the global health
architecture and to us commitments in
global health to try to measure
the impact of the u.s. programs in
global health and other entities in the
global health architecture on health
outcomes I know that sounds very obvious
but that has not typically been the case
in looking at these programs in in
financing and donor development for
example typically the amount of money
spent or a loan that was dispersed had
been the measure of success or in the
measure of progress and that's not
really the final and goal the end goal
is to reduce reduce disease burdens to
improve life expectancy to reduce infant
and child mortality to improve the
prospects of a pregnant woman in terms
of her mortality morbidity outcomes so
these are the these are the measures of
success that the international community
has to align itself with in in the in
the future years okay so you have
highlighted several of the
recommendations that the report makes
how realistic do you think the
recommendations are well I think the
report and the committee at large had a
very nice balanced healthy balance of
idealism and realism idealistically
there are some major goals that need to
be achieved and as I just said the focus
is on health and the health impact and
along those lines the Millennium
Development Goals the MDGs are our
dimensions of the measure of the health
impact so child mortality infant
mortality maternal mortality the disease
burden in terms of HIV and AIDS malaria
tuberculosis so you know there are dates
by which
the global community has suggested that
we in the broad sense achieve these
objectives and those are those are those
are difficult objectives but you know
they're there they're idealistic in some
sense but they need to be realistic in
the sense of really motivating people
and organizations to move forward
towards them the more organizational
efforts and their number there are a
number of different factors that have
that are a play in terms of achieving
health outcomes so it's very difficult
sometimes that's very difficult to
measure it's an attribute health impact
the organizational the governance
objectives I think are very realistic I
think that the United States has
identified through this report for the
new administration ways in which it can
reorganize and and coordinate and hold
itself accountable the new
administration is very focused on
outcomes and transparency and and very
pragmatic in those ways and I think this
fits very nicely with those objectives
so I think that's very realistic and we
can definitely be achieved similarly the
financial commitments certainly can be
achieved a doubling from 7 billion to 15
billion not that that small change but
and we have a scarcity now with the
current climate that the economic crisis
and the current legislation that's
that's being considered but that said
we're seeing that we've seen some early
signs that the current administration is
interested in global health
and has it has has some knowledge of
some of the issues and I think has shown
a commitment and I think it is fairly
realistic to assume that that
administration will take on that
particular recommendation I also think
that in terms of the portfolio and
focusing on the broader range of
diseases on and the health system focus
recommended by the report that that yes
that would fit very much with the new
administration's broader sort of view of
things and in particularly results on
the ground okay so you're optimistic
that the Obama administration will be
able to implement the recommendations so
there is hope that there will be an
improvement in global health well I
think that yes I think that I'm
optimistic about our current
administration and I'm also extremely
optimistic about the overall global
climate and the last two decades I don't
think I've ever seen a time where
there's been so much enthusiasm towards
global health we've seen doubling of
investments financially we've seen again
the introduction of a number of new
institutions and players we've seen so
enthusiasm i think is is quite quite
ample the that's why the governance
issues are so critical it's really
trying to coordinate and bring people
together on the same page to achieve the
results on the ground but but i do think
yes I think the u.s. administer the
Obama administration and also the global
commitment that we're seeing
is is ripe for a the implementation of a
report like the IOM has just pursued
wonderful that's good news thank you so
much for being here with us today and
sharing your insights on the IOM report
for more information about professor
Ruger her work and the IOM report please
visit our website at yale edu backslash
Macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale